so what brings you in well there's a lot
of things just those moments in the day
where I'm just like what's in the space
in between your hands my family I'm
required to inform you that I am NOT a
licensed psychologist that that these
therapy sessions of I had a record of
the clinical hours needed to acquire
such a license so your training
essentially yes I'm being mentored by a
therapist downtown David you're doing
therapy in a garage dear Peter nobody
likes you because you have a weird dick
that's not true it is Oh looks like a
slug is holding onto an egg what led you
to this decision I really want to help
people you know for money I just
graduated from medical school and I am
at the foot of a mountain of debt yeah
my cat got real sick she wouldn't need
51 cats getting sick constantly one of
them would have to have a massive cat
cocaine habit my god how old your
sessions been going with your patients
really really good
you're an [ __ ] I hate you so much I'm
gonna cut up your face weird on my ass
and [ __ ] out your mouth really
interesting so you hate him no I don't
hate him
I hate the sounds that come out of him
do you mean what he says no like
everything like chewing breathing do you
hear him right now David how many people
are you seeing I don't know oh I
probably shouldn't
well at least 20 but I've lost track at
this point
okay
[Music]
[Music]
of course there are disclosure
legalities of confidentiality so you
know possible terrorism elderly abuse
murder I would have to report those get
started and I will be recording under no
circumstances are you to engage in any
physical relations with the patient of
course yes
we can't stop thinking about my family
here my grandpa's name is David to [ __ ]
out so these rules start now right
you